I definitely plan every step of my life
too much way too much can we have our
differences like when Isis attract I'm a
clean freak so and she's an artist she's
messy I love cats
Ivan cats are great I definitely love
cats and I you know I've been wanting to
get one for a while I lived with this
black hat and he was just the sweetest
thing so I just grew to really love cats
after that I don't like anything
happening that I don't plan or come into
a plan with I'm definitely more of a dog
person I know if I could ever own a pet
cats they just poop in a box I just
would never get a cat okay you saw
should be coming up the stairs it
seriously any second now I'm very very
excited this is so cool okay Ivan's
about to walk in this is Kyle is our
kitty for the next week
okay so we're waiting for my roommate to
get home and we're hoping she's gonna
she's gonna like him I was where is he
gonna sleep we'll see who he likes
better you wanna hold it no not yet
where we're gonna put the litter box is
for the proofs and the piece both of
them this I know so how much do we put
in there I think I'm just gonna pour all
this in there oh it smells kind of good
night one with the cat Oh
Alison's gone for the first time and the
cat is in my chair
think I like I've been more than he
likes me
what did you just say I love the cat you
like him there this is not what I wanted
to happen it's what I am and his cat is
ready to play I'm making him scoops of
the boobs it doesn't smell as bad as I
thought it was going to
Oh Mele stepped in his own poop and now
a las colinas balls twice today needs to
be taken care of immediately
Alison won't be home for a while so yes
this is gonna be my responsibility it
actually smells better in here
Janos I've met other cats and they were
crazy I didn't know I could trust you
like this typically I'd be thinking
about what's on my calendar or where I'm
supposed to be but as of now I'm just
watching this happen I really hope I get
to keep this little guy when it's all
said and done update guys he started
coming to me as soon as I stopped paying
attention to him
he's sleeping me it's kind of cute
actually
kinda
yeah we became parents I don't know if
it suited us took a lot of time for him
to warm up to me probably because I I
come on a little strong there's really
no issue yeah I think this took us to a
new level in our roommate relationship I
think we've decided we're gonna keep for
us is it happening like which I wish I
literally did not think what happened
hey Eddie he's like oh yeah the family
this is where I belong yeah little tiny
furry kid in